a portion of today's episode is brought
to you by the Google pixel 3 hello
internets and this is film theory the
show where we always expose the
so-called heroes for the Psychopaths
that they really are today we're talking
about Captain Marvel can she be trusted
no no she cannot therefore we must band
together and Bram what's going on here
look it's a scroll impostor of me me yes
the the real mad bat no I'm pretty sure
that I'm the real matpat I think the
viewers are smart enough to tell the
difference right you very clearly
understand that this is me you can tell
based on that buttery smooth voice this
other guy's voice is all kind of
obnoxious
sounds like a Green Goblin ripoff look
at him over there with that smug grin
you know that this is the real mad Pat
because of this voice my voice is
annoying to a large majority of the
internet and you can tell that because
my voice is quite annoying right now I
mean look it's me I'm even holding a
diet coke looks like he's drinking a
mountain Dew or something I don't know I
don't I don't drink a mountain Dew at
the very least it would be a Diet
Mountain Dew diet sodas are just what I
prefer when stomach doesn't really
adjust all that well to fully sugared
sodas it's just the fact of the matter
you know that he's the imposter does he
even wear his hair that way no no he
does not probably not listen to these
episodes more his podcasts I'm not some
evil doppelganger how dare you suggest
that he even said hello Internet and
this is filmed that's not the phrase he
doesn't even know the phrase oh how
could you possibly go with this guy that
is not what I say every episode oh come
on
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the real film
theory accept no substitutes and how do
I know you're not a scroll now you're
kidding
as we prepare for the upcoming release
of Captain Marvel had become obsessed
less with her as a character and more
with her foes the shape-shifting Scrolls
as the trailers have shown anyone even a
kindly old grandma the Metro can turn
out to be a highly-trained deadly Skrull
warrior
well there's your first clue Captain
Marvel this is on the Los Angeles subway
no normal human being rides that thing
that's not a statement about people who
ride it it's more about Ellie's
lackluster public transportation system
anyway if you think Kevin Feige and the
team over at Marvel is gonna be content
with revealing one random little old
woman as a scroll then I don't think
you've been paying attention Captain
America's best friend killed Iron Man's
mom Loki has been written off as dead
multiple times oh yeah the entire good
guy team of shield turned out to be
controlled by their arch-nemesis Hydra
twist reveals are as integral to this
franchise as shots of topless men so
with Captain Marvel being the only movie
left before we head into the endgame in
the next phase of MCU I think we can all
expect one or two last big gut punch
reveals that some familiar face we've
been seeing over the last 10 years might
just be an alien in disguise so today it
is my goal to predict where the secret
scrolls are hiding in the MCU while also
exonerating any of the key suspects can
we see the twists coming before it hits
feeders probably not based on my track
record but that doesn't mean I'm not
gonna try using evidence logic and solid
narrative structure gosh darn it oh and
in case it wasn't obvious yet spoilers
for all the MCU movies up through
ant-man and blossom before we start
let's all review our Skrull basics to
ensure that we're working with the same
set of knowledge because the scrolls
haven't made an official MCU appearance
yet even if they have been there the
whole time in hiding it means that we're
not a hundred percent sure what features
of these characters will be used from
the original source material but it is
still probably the best place to start
the scrolls were an ancient race of
green skin humanoids with pointy ears
who were initially peaceful when
interacted with other civilizations due
to their genetic instability they are
blessed with the ability to shape-shift
making it easy for them to facilitate
trade and conduct diplomacy as a result
their civilization grew and prospered
well at least until they met the Creed
you're a pre a race of noble warriors
heroes you sure about that Captain
Marvel it must depend on who you ask
since our only exposure to the Kree up
to this point has been guardians of the
galaxy in which old purple eyes blue
dragon Ronan the accuser over here was
of the Kree race which should give you
some example of their disposition I
believe for 1,000 years of Kree justice
on Xandar someone's angry before the
scrolls and Kree go to war for hundreds
of thousands of years changing the
scrolls into a warrior race and from
there on out it's basically never a good
thing when either the Kree or the
scrolls show up on earth as I mentioned
the scrolls main ability is
shape-shifting and usually it's just
limited to that shape able to copy
practically anything organic like a cow
or inorganic like a lamb able to copy
inorganic things maybe the time stone
was actually a scroll in disguise but
that's not all they also have the
ability to copy memories making them
even harder to spot the scroll had her
appearance her voice yes but it also had
her memories she was a perfect copy in
every way
once you reveal a scroll the fights just
beginning well they're no problem for
heavy hitters like Thor or the Hulk
scrolls do have some serious superhuman
strength and a healing factor that's far
beyond that of a normal person there's
also a special species of so-called
super scrolls that can even absorb super
powers in the cancelled MCU tie-in video
game The Avengers there were even super
Skrulls that seemed to have absorbed the
powers of Hulk Captain America Iron Man
and Thor all at the same time that
pretty much makes everyone in the MCU a
suspect
no super-powered rage monster or
sorcerer supreme is fully safe from
suspicion but we
do some logical deduction to reduce our
list of suspects as bold of a move as it
would be I think it's pretty safe to say
that Tony Stark the de facto main
character of the MCU up to this point is
safe from being a Skrull if he was one
it would be coming out of nowhere and it
would vastly cheap in our entire
experience so far with this universe a
twist for twist sake just wouldn't be
worth undercutting a decade's worth of
emotional investment into this guy the
same can be said of Captain America
who's already dealt with multiple
imposter situations in these movies
between the Hydra reveal and the [ __ ]
as a killer reveal the trail is just
part of his everyday life
so for him to pull off the proverbial
scooby-doo mask to reveal himself as
someone different would just be
unmotivated bad storytelling next we can
reasonably eliminate the victims from
the snappin in infinity war up sorry
according to the novelized tie-ins it's
now called the decimation lame I like
dripping on terrible horror movie names
when the trees are out to kill humanity
what no hash tag snapping was happening
well regardless if they're going to all
the trouble to remove someone from these
movies just to bring them back they're
probably not gonna be a Skrull reveal
stacked on reveals just feel kind of
cheap from a storytelling standpoint or
if they did come back they'd come back
and scroll form in which case your Gong
sounds Franco are also included in the
group killed an infinity war would be
Loki who you know definitely isn't dead
yet but being a Skrull would just be too
many things that Loki is on top of not
being dead twice Clint Barton who you
may know as Hawkeye seems to be making a
return in the persona of Ronan and
endgame avenging his snap to a family
based on them saying nice family right
before showing him in his new outfits
it's not impossible that he's a Skrull
but it would greatly cheapen his dark
vengeance arc also safe from a
storytelling perspective his black widow
who was about to get her own movie going
into a solo movie as a recently outed
alien imposter is gonna really strain
fan acceptance of that new IP so it
certainly seems like she's gonna be safe
and lastly her beau Hulk who was
certainly acting strange and infinity in
the past Bruce could never remember
things that happened when he was the
whole who's Ashley kind of runs
you actually did today's house for a
while I did yeah what's happened you and
I had a fight did I win no I won he's
that and yet an infinity war he
remembers both Thanos and the Infinity
stones as banner
he's also the perfect candidate for a
scroll take over a generally confused
professor type who after age of Ultron
goes missing for years meaning there was
plenty of opportunity for the old
switcharoo with above-average knowledge
of the universe and a best friends list
that includes a bunch of superheroes but
I gotta take him off the list too since
Hulk as a separate entity inside banner
would certainly reject the imposter and
not in the way that we see in the movie
but even with that big chunk of
candidates out of the way we're still
left with a number of juicy options
first Thor the juiciest of the bunch
Thor just went through a massive
character change going from dark and
brooding and thoughtful at the end of
age of Ultron to a big old goofball in
Ragnarok sure that was a course correct
for a character who is struggling to
resonate with audiences but still that
change could be explained through a
scroll take over you no one else could
be explained through scroll control his
ineptitude when it comes to finding
Infinity stones at the beginning of Thor
Ragnarok he outright says this and I
went searching through the cosmos for
some magic colorful infinity stone
things didn't find any oh you didn't did
you
that's odd considering at the end of
Thor the dark world even this Asgard
grunt knows the location of two but if I
may ask why not keep it secure
the tesseract is already on us God is
not wise to keep two Infinity stones so
close together seems like not even Taika
Waititi director of Ragnarok was able to
get through the entirety of Thor dark
world and lastly let's be honest here
it's a bit weird that the god of thunder
is repeatedly taken out by an electrical
collar shock suspicious right that said
I'm gonna have to knock him off the list
for two reasons first his actor Chris
Hemsworth has hinted that there's more
for to come so doing a drastic character
upheaval like a scroll reveal would risk
reverting a character back to a more
boring version of himself when he'd
finally found the popularity he was
looking for with audiences and secondly
from a lore standpoint until the hammer
breaks and Ragnarok Thor carries it
around with no problem lifting the OL
near isn't a matter of strength or super
abilities but worthiness a scroll
pretending to be Thor wouldn't be seen
as worthy by the hammer and thus
shouldn't be able to lift it
therefore Thor is safe so who's left who
are the secret Scrolls or are we just
looking for reveals that'll never happen
I don't think so the first candidate I
and a bunch of other online theorists
feel really confident about is general
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross who I hear he
asking well Ross made his debut in the
second MCU movie ever released the oft
forgotten Incredible Hulk where he did
what general Ross always does in Hulk
stories he helps create the Hult and he
fights against the Hulk then he lets the
Hulk go before hunting him down yet
again he creates the Hulk in his
obsession with Captain America's Super
Soldier Serum then he uses Hulk to fight
against abomination but come Captain
America Civil War Ross is singing a
totally different tune the general has
quit the army and has now risen to the
role of Secretary of State but what
really stands out here isn't the change
in role it's his change as it regards
enhanced humans he's a strong advocate
for the sokovia accords which puts
restrictions on superhero activity
practically the opposite of his views in
Incredible Hulk he explains this change
viewpoint by telling a story after 13
hours of surgery
triple bypass I found something
perspective it's one of those oddly
specific moments in a movie that's
either lamb shading the clear retcon of
his character or its setting up some
oddly specific details that will pay off
once the change in perspective is
revealed to be a Skrull takeover anyway
he is now the driving force that's
trying to restrict the actions of heroes
he's the one responsible for a bill that
drives a wedge between the team thereby
weakening the Avengers and scattering
them across the globe making earth
vulnerable to scroll attack he has a
high rank not just in the military but
also in the government at a national and
international scale and his
reintroduction in Civil War and
shoehorning into infinity war after
eight years of silence in the MCU is
suspicious without measure especially
since his involvement in the former
movie was initially teased as being
quote a new general Ross and he don't
have to take my word for it from the
mouth of the actor himself quote what
they've done is they've taken a
character who was the Ross from the
older film and made a new version this
is a much newer Ross a much different
Ross and quote we're on to you new
general Ross gonna surprise anyone when
you reveal yourself as the little green
man you are on the inside so general
Ross in my opinion is almost certainly a
Skrull but that reveal isn't gonna be
all that impactful on anyone is anyone
really watching at home clutching their
General Ross action figures close to
their chest being like I can't wait to
see more from this guy no I would assume
not but there is still one very
interesting option whose impact might
have a little more Rhodey aka war
machine
James Rhodey Rhodes is Tony Stark's best
friend and as one of my earn man's
closest and oldest advisors he'd already
be a fantastic target for any
intelligence organization but Rhodey is
a double-whammy because he's also a
high-ranking Air Force officer with the
ability to call off strikes on hostile
aircraft that's a pretty handy ability
should the scroll be looking to attack
and that's before he even start
considering his possession and mastery
of a heavily armed mech suit he also
disappears with the Iron Man mark 2
armor for a suspicious
long amount of time in Iron Man 2 before
he takes it to his superiors in the
military we know that Tony lives in
Malibu California and we are expressly
told by the movie that Rhodey flies it
to Edwards Air Force Base which is close
enough that you could drive between the
two locations in a matter of hours and
yet here it is night today where were
you that whole time Rhodey may be given
that suit to your scroll friends for an
inspection from a narrative standpoint
Rhodey is one of the best possible
choices he's an important enough
character that he's a familiar heroic
face but he's not so important that him
having a secret identity would undermine
a lot of the emotional stakes that we
have in the more well-established
characters plus the reveal of Rhodey as
a scroll would be the final blow to Tony
who's already undergone so many changes
throughout these other movies he's
changed his motivations his morals he's
lost that arrogance and swagger with it
being replaced by paranoia he's
connected with a son surrogate that he
then loses and he's been forced to
question almost every belief that he had
back in 2008 when this whole mess
started
so for Rhodey to go and betray him
reveal that he had been body swapped
somewhere before
Iron Man 2 when Don Cheadle took over
the role then truly Tony would have to
question the last thing he has left his
faith in even his closest of friends but
for actual evidence we turn yet again to
Captain America Civil War he's one of
the very few Avengers to actually sign
the sokovia accords helping to ensure
the superheroes are restricted in their
actions
he's also badly hurt during that movies
Airport showdown when vision mrs.
Falcons wings and instead hits roadies
power supply causing him to plummet
hundreds of feet seeing the scene the
first time I was shocked then I was
shocked again that we were told that he
was still alive and only just paralyzed
a fall like that would kill any human
especially a human in hundreds of pounds
of armor no question but an alien that's
slightly stronger than a human and has
healing factor definitely a lot more
believable and speaking of that healing
factor roadies recovery is equally alien
in just two years in movie time he's
strong enough to fight in the battle of
Wakanda I don't buy it
sure Tony builds him artificial legs but
look at famous stuntman Evel Knievel who
fell from much lower
and broke no less than 35 bones in his
body his recovery time was often years
with himself reporting that he spent
more than half the years between 1966
and 1973 in hospitals in wheelchairs on
crutches there is no way that rody is
back to fighting for him that quickly
without some scroll levels of healing so
unless Rody's about to reveal that he's
been hiding wolverine in his basement
which I gotta admit would be a pretty
hilarious way to explain where the x-men
have been this whole time we may need to
start considering that Tony Stark's best
friend may not be who Tony thinks he is
but hey that's just a theory ah film
theory and cuts can we seriously talk
for a minute about how excited I am for
superhero movies at this point into the
spider-verse was so good one of the best
animated movies I've seen in a long time
the far from home trailer has me very
hyped to see my boy Mysterio on screen
and curious about where they're gonna
take that story not from a literal
standpoint since obviously it's all
about a trip through Europe and endgame
is the climax of a decade of incredible
superhero crossovers and you know when
he comes back from being dusted Peter
Parker's gonna be all about that epic
superhero selfie now that he's an
official Avenger
except there's one problem here how do
you cram all those capes and broad
shoulders together into one epic selfie
there's just too many of them especially
when one is a giant green rage monster
well it would be a problem if it wasn't
for the sponsor of this portion of
today's episode the Google pixel free
white literally the superhero of phones
and nothing shows this off better than
the phone's camera have too many
Superfriends in your shot well the pixel
three has dual front-facing cameras that
enables super wide shots turning the
selfie into the groupie no longer you
depended on the guy with the elastic arm
power to take the picture make sure that
you're getting your whole cell or the
superhero fight that's going on behind
you into the picture every time and we
all know that superheroes like to work
at night which leads to some terrible
photo ops typically the low-light would
produce something that looks like this
muddy and dark but with pixel threes
nitesite which uses a combination of
algorithms and machine learning the
picture becomes this not a moment of
copyright neutral crime-fighting will be
missed
seriously though this mode is like magic
and use it a lot during the holidays who
was incredible eat your heart out
sorcerer supreme and last but certainly
not least there's Top Shot where
Google's machine learning can process
the frames before and after the shutter
was pressed to find the best image of
you possible ensuring that every picture
gets smiles and not blinks which is a
great feature for family photos and
slightly less relevant if your face is
covered in an expression with superhero
masks to hide your secret identity all
the time so whether you're a teenager
looking to grab some great shots during
your international field trip struggling
to fit your whole superhero self in the
frame or just looking to put some better
selfies on the web of the world wide web
that is check out the pixel 3 quite
literally the superhero of phones for
more info check out the link in the
description now if you'll excuse me need
to go see spider-verse again there are
so many Easter eggs those are all
theories for another day
film theories and